[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce sont des images de l'avenir que nous
a apporté cette semaine la chèvre
nantais cnic de la première centrale
nucléaire française et des f1 sur le
territoire de la petite commune d'avoine
pas de chinon a dévoilé le spectacle des
centrales électriques de l'âge atomique
[Musique]
dès l'été prochain la sphère d'acier de
55 mètres de diamètre qui renfermera et
des f1 s'inscrira dans le paysage à côté
des parallélépipèdes de béton de et des
f2 et premiers kilowatts d'électricité
d'origine nucléaire partiront vers le
réseau de distribution
acino ce jour-là l'atome commencera à
prendre la relève des grands barrages et
de leurs usines hydroélectriques
[Musique]
aux états unis les images de l'avenir
c'est au chimpanzé et nosc on les doit
héros de la répétition générale du
voyage de l'homme américain autour de la
terre et nasa a été confiée dans une
capsule mercury à une fusée atlas
navette effectué trois rotations avant
d'être récupérée il n'en effectué a que
deux d'ailleurs parfaitement réussie
pour la plus grande satisfaction du
lieutenant colonel thana droite désigné
pour le premier vol humain et son
éventuel remplaçant scott carpenter
[Musique]
et nasa a été récupéré en plein
atlantique d'où on l'expédié à passer
une sérieuse visite médicale
et ne s'y mettra bien vivant mais l'oeil
un peu triste il est vrai qu'on serait
abattu à moi
[Musique]
il ne peut pas trop se fier à cette
courtoisie réciproque du japonais failli
sonner et du hollandais guessing dans un
instant ils vont totalement oublier
toutes ces politesses et alors ils vont
parler le langage des judokas un langage
qui se traduit par toutes sortes de
figures au nom bizarre mais comme nous
ne connaissons pas le japonais ben non
nous a regardé le pendre
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
ans
tout ceci se termine par la victoire
inattendue du hollandais qui devient
champion du monde avant d'affronter ses
supporteurs beaucoup plus dangereux
semble-t-il que le japonais
vingt mille stéphanois pour assister à
la résurrection de juste pantene le
numéro 8 du stade de reims maillot
français en mangent blanche ce numéro 8
c'est celui qui le porte est en suède il
ya trois ans alors qu'il était le
meilleur shooteur de la coupe du monde
depuis il s'est cassé deux fois la jambe
à propos de cette jambe un énorme point
d'interrogation
la réponse elle est simple regardez vous
même excellente passe aux partenaires
démarqués et ses miracles que reims ne
soient pas parvenus là à réussir un but
cette action favorable rémois ne doit
pas faire illusion c'est saint-etienne
qui a dominé durant les trois quarts de
la partie domination qui se traduit par
un premier but
et comme les stéphanois ont continué de
surplace et leurs adversaires ils ont
marqué un second but résultat reims
n'est plus en tête du championnat
[Applaudissements]
sans doute les coupables ont expliqué
leurs crimes sans doute un jour de 1946
l'amiral tojo et ses complices ont été
condamnés à la mort des criminels mais
il reste que rarement pareil attentats
ne fut tentée et réussie à l'aube du 7
décembre voici vingt ans sans
déclaration de guerre
361 avions s'envolèrent de porte-avions
qui sans être découvert s'était approché
de la grande base navale américaine du
pacifique
pearl harbour
quinze minutes suffirent pour réduire à
néant la plus belle et ce cadre du monde
ce fut sans doute le plus fulgurant
désastre navale de tous les temps 5
cuirassé détruits ou coup les trois
ravagé par l'incendié un grand nombre de
croiseurs et de destroyers détruit 3500
morts prix de l'impréparation et de
l'insouciance
se souvient ton de pearl harbour
l'évocation au louvre de l'atelier de
georges braque dans le prix que le monde
attache à cette artiste il est le
premier peintre vivant a exposé au
louvre cette reconstitution situe mieux
que toutes les études l'univers d'où le
peintre a tiré sa magie personnel c'est
ce compte inaugurer ensemble monsieur
andré malraux et l'artiste lui même avec
les quelques soixante toiles qui forme
non pas une rétrospective mais bien d'un
regroupement où s'offrent la continuité
d'une inspiration transfigura trice le
georges braque du louvre n'est en effet
pas différent du georges braque que nous
filmions dans sa retraite de
varengeville voici quinze ans et qui
poursuivait dans le silence cette
opération de mise en forme poétique des
objets quotidiens sous le signe d'un
cubisme élargi aux limites du songe
poétique
quel est dans l'art de notre temps la
place de georges braque ses notes sourde
de lumière qui illumine son oeuvre cette
reconversion des choses habituelles et
leur métamorphose poétique éclipse bien
des renommées tapageuse
saluons l'entrée au louvre d'un grand
peintre contemporain
[Musique]
en inaugurant devant le premier char à
bancs un moteur l'exposition le siècle
de l'automobile le ministre du commerce
et de l'industrie avait avant toute
chose à rendre hommage à l'audacieux
chercheurs qui imagina un moteur ou le
foyer serait logée dans un cylindre
l'inventeur etienne le noir se flattait
de supprimer ainsi la chaudière organes
encombrants et dangereux les résultats
de vente encourageant quand on s'avise à
d'employer un combustible gazeux ainsi
en 1861 acquis le moteur à explosion
l'automobile suivies dès 1891 la
construction série s'était emparé de
l'auto et les routes de campagne purent
admirer les modèles super chic du double
fight on chasse ibra ferrer allumage par
brûlures frein sur les bandages des
roues arrière et des qui pour empêcher
de dérivés on pouvait atteindre le 25 à
l'heure en 1895 l'utilisation du premier
pneu donner un nouvel essor à la voiture
et léon bollée présentait un tricycle
dont les 30 km/heure faisait trembler
les cyclistes en 1902 l'automobile
prenait du galon avec la course paris
vienne la première grande épreuve de
vitesse que gagner marcel renaud
avec les premier tour de france cycliste
l'automobile avait pris ses lettres de
noblesse la caravane suiveuse déjà été
automobile
le confort gagner des points l'élégance
en elle est portée à voile est charmant
cache poussière et l'ondulé premier
embouteillage
1904 marqua une grande date si paris
madrid s'arrêta à bordeaux on y était
allé à cent à l'heure ce furent les
premiers marty
[Musique]
l'automobile entré dans les moeurs
l'attelage à la donne on faisait place
sous le règne de monsieur phal hier aux
40 chevaux sous le capot
elle entrait aussi dans les mauvaises
moeurs la bande à bonnot fut son
initiatrice précurseur de tous les
gangsters sa voiture bono dès 1911 fille
de l'auto l'auxiliaire essentiel si
banal aujourd'hui de toutes les
agressions
[Musique]
la guerre de 14 devait donner à l'auto
le lustre de la gloire guerrière les
taxis de paris sont peut être les vrais
vainqueurs de la bataille de la marne
[Musique]
laperne à l'automobile à des
compétitions pacifique et avec ses
voitures à chenilles la croisière noire
traversait le savent
[Musique]
les premières voitures de course
apparurent sur le circuit de la sarthe
vous devez sortir un peu plus tard les
24 heures du mans
[Musique]
1940 supprime 1 à paris la circulation
automobile mais on vit naître cet oeuf
électrique qui semblait dire patience
automobile pas morte et nous en sommes
venus à cette merveille de mécanique que
prévoyait peut-être etienne le noir le
précurseur mais avaient ils prévu un
succès si total ces milliers de voitures
si parfaite qu'elle ne peuvent plus
faire que du 4 à l'heure
[Musique]